prosecutors in new york city have
revealed the criminal charges against
the trump organization
and its chief financial officer the
indictment accuses
alan weisselberg and the former
president's company of a fraud lasting
years jeff piguets is outside trump
tower in new york city jeff
how are they responding to these charges
well the trump organization says that
these charges are all about politics
allen weisselberg says that he's going
to fight the charges in court but when
you look at the charges
they really are a stunning list of
accusations dating back more than 16
years
a grand jury here in manhattan brought
the charges against weisselberg and the
trump organization
accusing them of running a tax fraud
scheme involving off the books payments
and concealing almost 1.7 million
dollars from the government
prosecutors say weisselberg failed to
report payments on benefits like luxury
cars
bonuses a company apartment a private
school tuition for
family members weisselberg was also
charged with grand larceny which carries
a 5 to 15 year prison sentence
mr trump slammed the charges as a witch
hunt from radical left prosecutors
and the trump organization called it an
inappropriate use
of a local prosecutor's vast and
unchecked power to target a political
opponent
this indictment really is going to put
pressure on alan weisselberg to flip on
his former boss because
if you look at the list of charges if
he's convicted
he faces the potential of decades
in prison and there could be more
charges in this case
because the grand jury hearing evidence
is impaneled
through november tony all right we'll be
following it jeff thank you very much